what's up guys we're at universal
orlando resort i'm marcus johns and i'm
tiffany smith for fandango and we are
here checking out the wizarding world of
harry potter diagon alley we're about to
do it
do you know harry potter my focus must
remain on the business
welcome to the night first emergency
transport for the stranded witcher
wizard my ex-boyfriend looks a little
like you
oh he does i shrunk his head wow he's a
good-looking
for any harry potter man this is the
coolest thing ever
oh
it turns out tiffany is actually
more powerful as a wizard than we
thought because it actually started
raining which is totally crazy i made it
poor rain how cool is that crazy we also
got to ride hogwarts express escape
gringotts and have all the butterbeer
this girl could ever possibly want and
wands and wands and wands of course if
you guys want to plan a trip make sure
you come down to universal studios
florida theme park for your own little
vacation see you next time
hmm
you